- [Narrator] Rarely do
nature and architecture
come together so perfectly,
as the divine Greek
monasteries of Meteora.
(orchestral music)
Meteora is a collection of
Greek Orthodox monasteries
perched on rock pillars
1,300 feet above ground.
They were built by Greek monks
from the 14th to the 16th centuries.
They were constructed by
using a network of ropes,
pulleys, baskets, and ladders,
which lifted supplies
up the dramatic cliffs.
In addition to solitude,
the location brought the monks and locals
a place of protection
from unwanted trespassers
and a sanctuary during
invasions from the Turks.
Today, only six of the
original 20 monasteries remain,
but they are still inhabited
by 20 monks and four nuns
who are full-time residents.
The Meteora is one of
only a handful of places
that are listed as a
UNESCO World Heritage Site
under two categories: nature and art.
Without changing the landscape,
the monks managed to build monasteries
that seem like extensions
of the mountain itself.
The name Meteora translates
to suspended in space.
And these monasteries
truly seem to defy gravity.
(upbeat music)
(electronic music)